at seven o'clock this is sky news
breakfast these are our top stories this
morning
police under fire officers accused of
being heavy-handed in breaking up a
south london vigil for sarah everard
with the met commissioner facing a call
to resign
a somber evening turned to anger and
protest
with clashes breaking out between police
and those in attendance
the met has defended its actions police
must act for people's safety this is the
only responsible thing to do
the pandemic is not over
also ahead child's gun crime a sky news
investigation reveals more than 600
children were arrested
for firearms offences last year for the
youngest just 12 years old
the metropolitan police's war crimes
unit launches an investigation into asma
al-assad the british-born wife of the
syrian president
northern ireland's air ambulance tell
sky news it's seen an upturn in mental
health emergencies
during the pandemic in a sport
all roads lead to paris for wales as
they stay on course
for a six nations grand slam
it's a morning of false promise for most
bright and sunny
but it's not going to last rain working
its way in from the northwest will
work its way towards the southeast and
it remains changeable after that all the
details coming up shortly
and at quarter to eight we'll take a
look at the papers with the
anthropologist marianna hotter and
former editor of the daily star dawn
neeson
[Music]
good morning welcome to sky news
breakfast thank you for joining us
the metropolitan police faces criticism
from across the political spectrum this
morning
over its handling of a vigil for sarah
everard with met commissioner cresta
dick urged to resign
officers clashed with crowds who
gathered on clapham common in south
london
in defiance of a police order as police
told people to go home
scuffles broke out and four arrests were
made priti patel
and sadiq khan both say they've demanded
an explanation from the met
ivor bennett reports now on how a night
that started peacefully
descended into one of disorder a warning
his piece contains
flash photography
they are images that have caused outrage
across the political spectrum
seemingly passive protesters swarmed by
dozens of officers
and dragged away in handcuffs one woman
was even pinned to the floor
[Applause]
they were among hundreds who defied
lockdown restrictions to attend a vigil
in honor of sarah everard on clapham
common
near to where the 33 year old went
missing
four arrests were made but it's the
officers who are now in the spotlight
the home secretary priti patel called
the scenes upsetting
she's asked the metropolitan police for
a full report
london mayor sadiq khan said it was
unacceptable while liberal democrat
leader sir ed davey
called for met commissioner cressida
dick to resign
last night it was one of her assistants
who faced the cameras
and defended the police response
officers on the ground were faced with a
very difficult decision
hundreds of people were tightly packed
together
putting opposing a very real risk of
easily transmitting kobit 19.
police must act for people's safety this
is the only responsible thing to do
the pandemic is not over and gatherings
of hundreds of people from right across
london and beyond
are still not safe police had urged
people to stay at home after an official
vigil was cancelled
but the local mp believes the violence
wouldn't have happened
had the original event been allowed this
is what happens when you restrict
people's right
to protest people were you know looking
to come together to hold
a very decent vigil socially distanced
that would have been martial that would
have been protected people would have
dispersed within an hour they would have
been
holding a minute silence you know
honoring sarah
honoring all of the women that we've
lost to violence and they would have
gone home
earlier the man charged with kidnapping
and murdering sarah everard appeared at
westminster magistrates court arriving
out of sight in a police van
48 year old wayne cousins will appear
again at the old bailey on tuesday
as well as remembering sarah everard
organisers of the vigil hoped it would
shine a light on the issue of violence
against women
while that was still done last night on
doorsteps across the country
campaigners say they're not giving up on
holding mass gatherings in the future
i will continue to have regular
conversations with the metropolitan
police
and police up and down the country so
women can hold events like this
and it is it is our human right to
ensure that we can gather peacefully
but in clapham last night a largely
peaceful protest
turned violent and today it's the police
who are under scrutiny
iva bennett sky news
[Applause]
well melinda vasilinovich is on clapham
common in south london where that vigil
took
place last night and melania how have
people been reflecting on what took
place last night
well jillian since first light people
have been gathering at this makeshift
memorial
behind me leaving flowers in memory of
sarah everard
and other victims of violence after a
very emotional week erupted
in those ugly scenes last night the
original vigil
which was due to be organized by a group
called reclaim these streets was
cancelled because the police said that
it breached
lockdown restrictions but nonetheless
people started arriving
from early in the afternoon including
the duchess of cambridge
who took a few moments to reflect at the
memorial we know from the palace that
this was because she remembered what it
was like to walk the streets of london
at night before she was married but that
somber atmosphere really darkened as
night
fell and the police moved to try to
disperse the gathering they also
prevented a few of the women from
addressing the crowd
from the bandstand and the mood turned
angry you could see images of police
officers in some cases
tackling the women to the ground leading
them away
in handcuffs rather ugly scenes we have
heard from the police that they felt
they had no choice but to enforce
there were four arrests for breaching
lockdown as well as for public order
offenses but
many have argued that in this mood of
national outrage over the murder of
sarah everard they could have predicted
that people would have come
regardless of the restrictions that
perhaps would have been better
to allow the original vigil to go ahead
and said we are left with these images
of
in some cases male officers manhandling
the women
not the kind of message you'd want to be
sending in a week like this
okay milana thank you let's speak now to
our political correspondent rob
powell and rob politicians across the
spectrum
seem to be united in their criticism of
police tactics
yeah we have heard from all the various
uh
parties not exactly criticism i guess
from the government pretty patel yet
but saying that she wants more
information
she tweeted quite late last night saying
that some of the footage circulating
online from the vigil in clapham is
upsetting
i've asked the metropolitan police for a
full report
on what has happened now the reason for
that is that even during a lockdown
there's always a large degree
of operational flexibility and
discretion that's given to police
on how to manage protests like this
and that's why there are questions over
whether their response was heavy-handed
i think it was always going to be
a very challenging situation for the met
to handle
given the context of the pandemic and
the stay-at-home
order and that some previous protests in
london anti-lockdown protests for
instance have been met
and with quite a firm response but i
think given the circumstances of sarah
everard's
recent death the people are asking
questions whether a similarly firm
response
that has happened in the past was
appropriate this time round especially
as
for much of the time and for the
overwhelming majority of people there
anyway this was a largely
um peaceful demonstration i think
another question though as molena was
raising there
is really going one step before
last night and asking whether the met
police's apparent flat-out rejection
of any kind of vigil was the right
decision remember that court case on
friday while it didn't allow a vigil it
didn't say that one was definitely
lawful
it didn't completely close the door to
it either and i think given that the
organizers
were pretty open about how they wanted
to take quite extensive steps to make it
covered secure
many will wonder whether it would have
been a better idea to have an organized
event rather the more ad the more ad hoc
event we had last night
i think potentially questions for the
government though as well about the lack
of clarity
um when it comes to protests in the
covid rules so questions for the home
secretary questions
for the mayor of london who has ultimate
responsibility for policing but i think
probably the biggest questions for the
commissioner of the metropolitan police
crestor dick
who is facing some calls to resign this
morning
indeed rob thank you very much for the
moment maria miller is a conservative mp
and former minister for women and
equality she's also formally chaired the
commons
women and equalities committee joins us
now good morning
to you um i note that on monday on
international women's day you open the
commons debate and you said that we
should not accept a culture of violence
towards women we should not be complicit
in covering it up the suggestion there
that that perhaps
it is being covered up are we complicit
in that
when you look at the data it's really
clear that most women
don't report sexual harassment yet it
affects the vast majority
of women in this country and i think the
met police really have to rethink their
strategy for how they're handling this
uh rather than telling women not to
worry and
stopping them speaking out i think they
need to start to listen to what the
experiences of women
in this country really are in particular
what did you make of the the handling of
the vigil last night the police tactics
used
well i think it was incredibly
heavy-handed and what was planned was a
peaceful vigil
and that could have allowed women to
really show the
outpouring of concern about
the tragic death of sarah everard
because it really um speaks to their
experiences as women
the sexual harassment being something
that most women have to tackle on a
regular basis
um so let's listen to women rather than
trying to shut them up
just to say some of the images we might
be showing do have a flash photography
um there have been calls for at least
one call for
the uh met commissioner christa dick to
resign
would you agree with that call do you
think that she should resign over this
i think what she needs to do is to use
her very extensive experience to
get a much better approach to this um
this is a tragic situation
but to have the met police call it a
rare occurrence and
almost urge women to stop making such a
big deal of it is is just wrong and
it is a big deal this affects women
every
day of the week and there are some
really good examples
of how other parts of the police have
actually tackled this so
let's look at this positively as a way
of trying to get change on an issue that
really affects women's lives
as you say police um well they have a
degree of operational
flexibility what would you have liked to
see
yesterday instead of the scenes that
some of the scenes that we're seeing and
the arrests that were made
how could they have managed the
situation a lot better
oh look as with many of the black lives
matters protests which also
happened during the pandemic you know
the police were able to
understand that people need to have uh
an
opportunity to express their feelings uh
you know we live in a country where we
expect that as a matter of course
but i would also like to see the police
really advocating
for change on these things uh the laws
some laws are there some laws need
changing the data we collect
is very poor that needs to change
you know let's work together on getting
a better approach to sexual harassment
and the sorts of things that were being
protested about yesterday
uh rather than getting ensnared in a
situation where
uh we're trying to silence the real
concern that women have
we must remember that it didn't start
out as a protest started out as a vigil
and pretty patel's calling for a full
report into what actually happened but
the police
were acting um under her orders
look i think what we need to focus on is
how we can move forward and the
pretty patel has been very clear that uh
in her comments earlier that we do need
to look at whether the laws need to be
changed in
in this uh in these sorts of
circumstances
where women experience sexual harassment
should we be
dealing with that differently that's
what we need to be focusing in on
because after all uh the police can only
police these sorts of situations of
sexual harassment when uh they have the
right laws in place so rather than
i think focusing in on the protest what
uh and the vigil
what i would like to see is a real focus
on how we can support the police to do
that
job better to keep women safer
maria miller thank you very much for
speaking to us this morning
a sky news investigation shows more than
600 children in the uk were arrested for
suspected firearm offences last year
it includes children as young as 12
being detained by police for alleged gun
crimes
david mercer has the story
kabir kareem often returns to this
street in west london
his 20 year old brother alex was shot
dead here in june
police believe alex was killed in a case
of mistaken identity
a 16 year old boy was one of nine people
arrested over his death
and eight months after alex's funeral no
one has been charged
i'm able to come here sometimes i have
to come here just to reflect
i feel almost coming here just you know
i think coming is
it's the closest that i'll i'll get to
almost reliving him and why
because this was his last steps this was
his last breath
you know about like my mom's she can't
handle it honestly the last time she
came here she was
she was hysterical she was in tears she
was screaming she was wailing in the
street
the police in parts of the country are
worried about gun crime
and children are getting involved sky
news can reveal more than 600 children
were arrested for suspected firearm
offences in the uk last year
the youngest was 12. police figures
obtained by sky news show that
171 used were detained by the
metropolitan police for alleged firearm
crimes in 2020
that was up from 165 the previous year
in the west midlands 86 children were
arrested over firearms
among them two twelve-year-old boys and
on merseyside a fourteen-year-old girl
was arrested for a suspected firearm
offence
two years earlier an eleven-year-old was
arrested there for a firearm crime
the west midlands had some of the most
alarming figures
and one former gang member who carried a
gun when he was 15
has seen it coming the real issue is it
all really boils down to
a way of thinking a mindset and a
culture
a culture that's been pushed and is
thriving
throughout um the whole country it
started off in
little communities like mine but this
mentality this way of thinking
is like a virus it spreads it started
spreading throughout the school systems
i remember seeing it
when i had just left school started
getting into
um gang violence and crime
and the way of thinking started to
spread it was just
my community at first now it's asian
it's the asian community it's the white
community
it's everyone the national police chiefs
council said overall gun crime in the uk
remains low
it said it's working to break the cycle
of young people becoming involved in
gangs
alex karim would have turned 21 this
month
he'd plan to go to university to study
computer science
his family believes someone out there
knows who killed him
david mercer sky news
the prime minister is set to outline
plans to bolster britain's cyber
security next week
it follows a review of the government's
foreign and defense policy
boris johnson will commit to take a full
spectrum approach to cybercrime in a bid
to keep people safe and stay ahead of
the uk's enemies
he's set to announce plans for a cyber
corridor across the north of england
where the headquarters of the new
national cyber force will be based
meanwhile the commons defense committee
has criticized the british army's ageing
tank fleet
saying it could leave the uk outgunned
and overmatched in a conflict with
russian forces
in a new report the group of mps says a
series of procurement failures has left
the army with some military vehicles
dating back
to the early 1960s i fear there's been
too much of a
perhaps a lure towards the digital
domain towards
cyber security towards you know the
space command and so forth
and but we you know we drop our guard
from the conventional side
as our peril and yet this is exactly
what i see this integrated review taking
us to
the nhs is to text millions of
vulnerable people with underlying health
conditions asking them to take up a
coronavirus vaccine
the health service will send out around
2 million messages this weekend to
people with conditions such as diabetes
and certain cancers
let's take a look at the latest
coronavirus figures now and 5
534 new cases were recorded in the
latest
24-hour period with another 121 deaths
that takes the total number of people
who've died to 125
465 the figures also show that 23.68
million people
have now received a first dose of a
coronavirus vaccine
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
hello there good morning to you well
we've actually got the sun coming
through the window here at sky this
morning it's absolutely glorious
uh it's not going to last though these
things don't at the moment it's all
rather changeable and it's not just
us it's all of northern europe as well
so we're at low pressure to the north of
us more rain making its way in and this
is going to work its way from the
northwest
down towards the south east so first
thing this morning
as i say plenty of sunshine for central
and eastern parts it looks absolutely
glorious it is quite chilly out there
though
and throughout the day it is going to be
windy so whatever the temperatures are
is going to feel colder anyway
already showers over western parts rain
over western parts of ireland
worked its way into western parts of
scotland northern parts of wales by the
middle of the day
temperatures between 10 and 12 degrees
celsius that's 54 degrees fahrenheit
and then through the afternoon that rain
makes its way into the midlands east
anglia
down into the southeast as well and the
sky is bright across scotland and
northern ireland leaving a mixture of
sunny spells
and scattered showers and then through
this evening and overnight it becomes
dry so another bright start to monday
morning
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
it's still to come we have all the sport
with jackie the rugby was good wasn't it
it was really exciting wasn't it
depending on which side of the fence you
fought
but you know it's pretty much wells in
the driving seat but we're going to tell
you why mario
toji's late try against france will have
been shared by england
and wales fans in the six nations plus
champions calling manchester city might
just have one hand on the premier league
title
after another clinical display last
night and it's all smiles from lee
westwood who is one
round away from what could be one of the
biggest wins
of his career
[Music]
me and my friend rob uh we decided we
would
set ourselves this challenge to swim in
the sea for 365 days without wetsuits
raising money and awareness for local
charities and community projects
shoalstone seawater pool and also the
seal project which is a local
conservation project and it's rob's idea
to be honest he invited me for a swim
back in 2019 one day turned into two to
a week to a month
before you know it we were swimming for
an entire year
in the winter months it does get a bit a
bit windy and a bit cold but ultimately
we was uh we was committed
um and we was uh you know very very keen
to
to do every single day and raise that
money and awareness so um
to be fair once we was into it it wasn't
a problem and uh
the sort of adventure and the things we
get to see are just
breathtaking this is a a a spider crab
sort of uh malt they come into the bay
once a year
in their thousands tens of thousands uh
and they pile up they come into
malt so they they remove their shells
and they mate and then they go again so
it's probably about a few weeks
you get this sort of mass of spider
crabs
we see regularly see um seals because
uh it's a seal habitat where we live um
but this is a sort of uh it's quite rare
these kind of encounters especially with
the seals
and although we do uh live and swim in a
seal habitat they um they rarely come up
to you this is uh
you know these are very rare occasions
but we set up the challenge for for
other people to do and that's the the
whole sort of point of it now really
and we're now a community interest
company and we're looking to recruit
more
sea swimmers and wild swimmers who want
to give it back to their communities
raise a bit of money for their charities
and also help us out as well
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
jackie is here with all the sport one
name mario togi
i think england fans do love him too as
well yeah we're gonna be talking six
nations
um also um tributes still continuing to
pour in for murray walker the voice of
f1 and speaking of in the driving seat
lee westwood he very much is at the
players championship let's have a look
this sports bulletin is brought to you
by vitality committed to getting 100
million people 20
more active by 2025
is this the future with its rush of air
crunch of gravel and electric wine
extreme e sounds and looks like nothing
else
and is progressive enough and
competitive enough to hook
jensen button as a team owner button
who not so long ago seemed an electric
skeptic
if i'd said to you five years ago you'd
be racing in an electric series would
you have
laughed at me look at it it's it's so
cool
it's so exciting you know this is an
electric vehicle that has 550 horsepower
initially we ran at 60
power i was thinking it's not very quick
and then we turn it up to a hundred and
wow the series five rounds will be held
at global sites relevant to climate
change from oil rich saudi arabia
to a worryingly ever greener greenland
but to maximize the messaging on global
warming
must the racing be red hot and like the
ecoscience contents running in tandem
easy to follow the format is going to be
really short races
you know our attention span these days
it's not great i mean we're doing an
interview here and neither of us are on
our phones which is unusual
um we're going to be racing in places
around the world that no one's really
ever
put a foot down on the sand or on the
dirt
so for us it's an amazing experience
xtremi enjoys relevance to the growing
electric road car market
but unlike formula e a series button
declined to join
avoids unfavorable comparisons with f1
perhaps as a result it's attracted three
f1 world champion
owners with nico rosberg and button's
fellow britain
sir lewis hamilton also signed up
well sebastian loeb is in lewis
hamilton's car so i think
lewis's team is pretty strong and nico
rosberg has a team as well
so um it's f1 world champions re you
know reuniting
in terms of its purpose format and
presentation
extreme e is different will it create a
buzz
craig slato sky sports starts
i'm in i'm in we're ruling to kick it
out
partnering to end racism in sport
i'm erin mckellar and i've been a
football youth coach
and mentor for over 40 years
we're at the training ground for the
late night youth team
i've been very privileged to work with
some really really fantastic
footballers the likes of soul campbell
ashley cole
ledli king but when they're passionate
and they're good at what they're doing
your job is not that difficult all
you've got to do is
keep enhancing them working with their
dreams if we don't make them become
footballers we make them become better
people
trust these guys they will get you there
thank you guys i wasn't always a
football coach
i started off as a mechanic that was my
day-to-day job
you know everything was fine until i was
diagnosed with prostate cancer
i found out about prostate cancer purely
by accident when my wife sharon was
complaining about me snoring
went to the doctor i picked up a leaflet
from prostate cancer uk
and the young lady said you don't need
to make an appointment this is a simple
blood test that takes less than 10
minutes i get a phone call
could i come in and have a biopsy done
moving on from that i had a scan
the doctor said mr mckellar your
prostate is covered in cancer
if we don't remove your prostate you
could be dead in six months
and i remember sitting in my car
i just burst into tears because i didn't
know what to do next and my wife came in
the car and she said look in all the
years that i've been with you i've never
seen you quit on anything that you've
ever done
she said this cancer has only knocked
you down it hasn't knocked you out
and i took that as an inspiration
so i had the operation to remove the
prostate i had to have
nearly three months of radiotherapy to
get rid of the risk of the cancer
the first day i went back into my garage
a gentleman came in to
have some work done on his car and i
said um when was the last time you had
your prostate checked
and he said what the bleep bleep bleep
has that got to
my gearbox not working and i said to him
listen i'll give you a 20
discount on the work i'm going to do on
your car if you go and get your prostate
checked
two weeks later he came back he had
a 25 cancer in his prostate
he said to me look don't worry about the
money more importantly i think you need
to start raising the awareness of this
issue
right because i wouldn't have gone and
done this check
had you committed to getting 100 million
people 20 more active by 2025.
[Music]
this is sky news breakfast coming up the
12 year old from wiltshire who's been
undertaking
a kp challenge to raise money for the
[Music]
nhs
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to sky news breakfast sky
news understands that the metropolitan
police has launched a preliminary
investigation into asma al-assad
the british-born wife of syrian
president bashar al-assad
is accused of supporting and encouraging
terrorism
if charged it could pave the way for the
met to seek her extradition
this month marks 10 years since the
start of the war in syria
which has left an estimated 400 000
people dead and more than six point
five million others displaced sadia
chowdhury reports
london born asthma al assad may have
seemed out of place in syria when she
first married one of the arab world
strongmen
i was born and raised in london i know
the central line extremely well
whether it was going to school going to
university but over time
the former investment banker and wife of
president bashar al-assad
has cemented her position as one of the
most powerful people in the country
now sky news understands an
investigation in her birth town could
lead to charges
that she supported and encouraged
terrorism
[Applause]
bashar al-assad has denied war crimes
and says instead
he has been fighting terrorists british
lawyers say the syrian government is
guilty of a systematic approach to the
torture and murder of civilians
including with the use of chemical
weapons
and that asma al-assad is among a number
of influential actors
that have encouraged and incited acts of
terrorism and
international crimes theoretically if
the metropolitan police agree with that
which has been submitted
and further evidence that they may
uncover during their own investigation
then they can seek to bring charges and
they can seek to
extradite her to the uk in a statement
the metropolitan police service told sky
news
we can confirm that the mets war crimes
unit part of the counter-terrorism
command
received a referral on 31st of july 2020
relating to the ongoing syrian conflict
the referral is in the process of being
assessed by officers from the war crimes
unit
former friends of the couple say her
influence is growing
with reports she has political ambitions
to climb to the very top
you cannot compare the existing asthma
asthma assad to the previous virgin
which is emma al-akhras in london till
now when she succeeded to consolidate a
lot of power now she's number one
in in economy in syria and the one that
run all the development about
administration and economy last year she
was sanctioned by the u.s government
despite this asthma al-assad's influence
doesn't appear to be wavering
but how she uses that power is now under
scrutiny
sadia chowdhury sky news
now many of us uh will have taken up new
hobbies in the past year to break up
the monotony of lockdown for one
football loving 12 year old from
wiltshire that new hobby was
kipi uppies which he's used to raise
money for the nhs
alfie pavlat walsh and his mum amy
island join me now
welcome to you both um i can see that
you've got the ball at the ready
ready to start those qp's for us um
alfie can you tell us before we get into
the football what
what life how would you compare life
before the pandemic and after the
pandemic
how how did you find that the change in
your situation
before lockdown i was doing like lots of
football sessions every night
and then when looked like you know i
started like having nothing to do i was
getting bored
so then i just started practicing
keyboards and amy what sort of changes
did you see
in alfie during the the lockdown
yeah he was um he was super excited to
start with obviously
sort of being off school um and then he
sort of mentally quite strong like
struggled quite a lot because he
is always he's never at home never at
home he does football six days a week so
every evening we're out
at the weekends we're out and then he
was you know 24 7 at home and he he
really really struggled with that
alpha you must have been so bored so
then where did the idea
come from to raise some money for the
nhs via kps
you're kind of just like the nhs are
struggling and i've seen other people
been setting themselves challenges to
raise money
so i thought i'll just give it a go it
came off keep ups
shall i set you a challenge and see if
you can do keepy uppies for the rest of
this interview
while speaking what do you reckon
are you up for the challenge all right
let's go for it right next question to
you then
mom um so this was all set up on
instagram um which obviously alfie isn't
old enough to use so you've set that
that up on instagram and what sort of
reception did that receive
yeah it was really really good there's a
lot of children in a similar situation
to alfie
um so it was kind of connecting with
other you know youth football players
football players
um there were a lot of sort of giveaways
and
sessions that he could do online from
that and it just built
built the community like a big community
really there's some really fantastic
players out there and alfie's learned a
lot from them and it's
really kept them busy i guess over over
the lockdown periods
let's see if alfie can talk and keep
doing that and alfie how much money did
you raise for the nhs
1 250 pounds
well done well done well done um and
so you've raised this money for the nhs
and you set this up on instagram
but amy you had to to manage the account
unfortunately you you know encountered
some some issues with that
yeah absolutely um we've we've sort of
had
some quite indecent messages not from
children but from
adults um and it just it sort of opened
my eyes to how serious
sort of the internet safety aspect of
things
is and we've shared all the information
with alvin you know we've told him about
these messages and things
because obviously he is in a couple of
weeks he's going to be old enough to
sort of have his own accounts and things
um and he's got access to the account so
there's always a chance that he could
see it
and so we've had these conversations
about you know internet safety
um we've even had to get the police
involved in some of them the local
police have been fantastic
uh but it just it sort of really opened
our eyes to it and also to alfie's
friends because he can then share
you know his experiences with those as
well yeah no it is really worrying you
do have to be so vigilant don't you
and alfie what are your aspirations for
your future footballing career what are
you hoping to achieve
apart from kids i'm hoping to do a
professional trouble
fifteen i'm gonna try and be a
freestyler what was that i missed that
when i'm older i want to be a freshman
footballer but if i don't quite make i
wanna be a freestyler
right professional footballer and who do
you support now
liverpool yeah i can i can manage that
always still keeping the ball up in the
air alfie keep going
thank you so much for speaking to us
this morning uh alfie and
amy good to see you and keep that ball
in the air
thank you thank you so much he's still
going
now even as the number of deaths from
covid19 falls medical staff are still
coping with huge and changing demands on
services
the air ambulance crew in northern
ireland has told sky news that uh since
lockdown has brought a surge in
life-threatening injuries caused
by mental illness our senior island
correspondent david blevins went out
with the service
[Music]
this wasn't staged for the cameras
northern ireland's air ambulance
is responding to a live call the crew's
mission as always
is to preserve life minutes later
they're putting this training into
practice incubating a patient
okay folks so just to recap where we are
obviously we've extricated this patient
he's fallen 20 every day begins with
this kind of exercise
and ppe has brought unique challenges
well one of the biggest challenges is
communication you know i'm talking to
you tonight with normal tone of voice
but we've had to raise that up whenever
we're speaking and particularly in an
aircraft we're wearing our helmets we're
wearing these
masks so i'm talking to the pilot
talking to the doctor
and sometimes you've got to yeah speak
louder and
really reliant upon of communication
standby for details it isn't long before
they're doing it for real
ambulance headquarters in belfast is
requesting the helicopter emergency
medical service they quickly deploy from
their base
formerly the site of northern ireland's
notorious maze prison
from this place long associated with
death they are saving life
but the pandemic poses a real threat in
the confined space of an
aircraft
within five minutes of the 999 call this
crew can be on board
and ready for departure but it doesn't
matter what kind of incident they're
responding to
they now have to assume that every
patient is covered positive
covert has increased the number of
incidents they're keen to ease the
pressure on their land colleagues
rooftop landings at the royal victoria
hospital have become routine
but increased isolation during lockdown
has changed the nature of calls
they're dealing with an upsurge in
life-threatening injuries
caused by attempted suicide a variety of
traumatic injuries that are a result of
mental health and
the stresses of society dealing with the
coveted pandemic and we are able to
to bring interventions airway secure
ongoing cpr you know for prolonged
arrests
and that's certainly probably one of the
stark things i've noticed while there's
maybe been a dip
in some of the road traffic collisions
that we attend
they're not the front line in the fight
against covid they're a critical
backline
trauma doesn't stop during a pandemic
tomorrow will bring different challenges
for northern ireland's air ambulance
team david blevins
sky news at the maze
and if you find you're struggling with
some of the same feelings covered in our
report you can contact the samaritans
for
help their telephone number and email is
at the bottom of the screen for you now
time now for a look at the weather with
joe
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
hello there good morning to you probably
best to look at this morning's weather
rather than this afternoon's weather
it's certainly the better part of the
day for everybody this morning it's a
mostly dry and bright start with some
bright or sunny spells
there are just one or two showers around
western coasts and some rain making its
way into western parts of ireland
and this is going to be the flying
annoyment through the day
so the rain makes its way into western
parts of scotland across northern
ireland into northern parts of wales by
the middle of the day
and then presses on down into the
midlands
and out towards the southeast and east
anglia by this evening
temperatures today 11 or 12 degrees
celsius 54 degrees fahrenheit it will be
windy
everywhere but sky is brightening up
towards the north and the west later and
overnight it becomes dry
tomorrow we'll be dry bright and fine
again
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
it's 7 44 you're watching sky news at
breakfast still to come
we'll take a look at the newspapers with
the anthropologist mariana hotter and
former editor of the daily star
dawn neeson do stay with us
this is good technology which has been
around for a few years but hasn't been
very widely used
and what we'd like to do is to roll it
out much faster we're planning to
test 11 000 people over the next year or
so across england
to see whether they have the early signs
of bowel cancer or to give them the all
clear
and obviously the nhs has been under
huge pressure during the pandemic we've
got
lists of people waiting for
colonoscopies we diagnose more than 100
people a day
with bowel cancer and we have to test
many times that with a colonoscopy
usually
so this is one way to help take some of
the pressure off those waiting lists
at the same time as bringing in a
technology which is potentially much
more convenient for patients of course
they come through in a few days you have
to analyze the images that come off the
recorder that people wear when they take
the pill
but then they come through very quickly
indeed we have we have people trained
to read the images that come from the
capsule
they produce a report and those then go
back to the patient very quickly so it's
a
it's a very straightforward way of
looking for things like polyps in the
bowel or early cancers
and of course that's what we want is to
be able to catch cancer at an early
stage when it's most curable
um it's really just for cancers in the
bowel
it will of course examine the other
parts of the intestine as it passes
through and in fact i had a patient come
to me the other day
who'd had one of these capsules who had
a tumor in their small intestine which
is
which is much less common but generally
speaking the main thing we're using it
for is to look for bowel cancer
[Music]
[Applause]
this is a forgotten front line they are
dying here
[Music]
boys we've got some interesting ways of
showing you what's going on their
message to us
get ready instructing you to stay at
home
i can't believe we did that it's pretty
special isn't it
i'm siobhan robbins sky southeast asia
correspondent in bangkok
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
[Music]
did you know that air pollution isn't
just bad for the environment
it's bad for our health too
[Music]
it'll be a chilly start for many parts
of the country with some good sunny
spells
just a few showers over western coasts
but later on we'll see cloud increasing
in the northwest bringing rain to
western scotland northern ireland
and then that will travel its way south
eastwards to reach east anglia
and the far southeast by evening clearer
skies will
follow with just a few showers and it
will be windy throughout the day those
winds quite strong and gusty at times
however these continuing unsettled
conditions do mean that
air pollution is likely to remain low
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
with us now to take us through the
newspapers once again the anthropologist
marianna hotter and the former editor of
the daily start dawn
neeson welcome back to you uh let's
start with the mail
at front page and uh dawn you've had a
look at this story
um talking about the rules recruiting um
a legal firm this is
to help presumably with their um
domestic affairs the the
the rows that we've seen indeed jillian
uh this is the ongoing fallout from
oprah winfrey's interview with megan and
harry which
most people saw last week and some
shocking allegations
um revealed in that however this is also
now about the bullying allegations that
have recently been made about megan
by members of staff on which buckingham
palace have now announced
they are bringing in an external
independent legal firm to carry out at
the
an investigation in his allegations um
the duchess of sussex
has to be said has also got um her
people to request to um
be see sight of the allegations the
emails the letters the complaints
against her
so it does sound like this is not going
away
any time soon um and you know
your heart goes out to the queen who you
know the husband in hospital
and where she's 94 with everything else
going on
um this is the the last thing she needs
however
like any complaint of bullying it has to
be properly investigated now
so you know it's a good thing go out to
megan who's had these claims made
against her um and
she's pregnant at the moment do you not
feel any sympathy towards her
absolutely absolutely it's it's this is
not good on either side julian it's
incredibly stressful situation um it's
it just seems to be getting worse on a
daily basis now you know
you you feel for everybody involved but
these claims have to be investigated and
you know in a way
the fact that an independent legal firm
has been brought in to carry it out
hopefully we'll see some closure on on
this this awful basically a family mess
isn't it that might be the royal family
but it's still family it's a family that
really
are being ripped apart by this yeah no
no um
ugly however you look at it to the times
uh mary anne and the voluntary services
overseas are
cutting their work with the uk tell us
about this story
yeah that's right so the voluntary
services overseas the vso
has is a charity that's been around for
50 odd years
and um often they help people from
um underrepresented or deprived
backgrounds
have an experience of being effectively
a kind of
a world citizen um or an international
citizen
and through that effectively are
promoting um
the the values and the principles that
we uphold in the uk
in british um life and and genuinely
helping um people in countries where
um they've got you know development and
goals
so their budget is about 42 million
pounds
and up until this year they've relied on
about
half of uh that coming from the uh what
is now the foreign
commonwealth and development office so
the fcdo
and the fcdo have now said well foreign
aid budget is being cut
uh we need to look after our own first
so we're not going to spend as much
money on international development on
foreign aid um so they've they've
basically said that we can't guarantee
funding to the vso after the 31st of
march and so the vso have said basically
we're now facing a cliff edge we can't
operate with half of our budget so
they'd wind down uk operations they'd
withdraw from
um like 14 countries they'd
have to make 200 people redundant and i
just think this is an absolute travesty
we can't allow really the government to
sort of say oh well you know we've got a
pandemic to sort out
because organizations like the vso
are built on experience and authority
and trust that they've built up with
their partner organizations in countries
around the world
and they do such uh wonderful work i i
remember being taught by a vso teacher
how to swim
out in the caribbean of all places um
yeah so
great organization great charity let's
have a look at um this story in the
times dawn you've had a look at this
um a database dangerous men on a
database i haven't got the exact
article here fill us in it's right okay
with this as you say julian
the times the ministers are considering
plans for a national register
to um create a super database that would
log details of the estimated
50 000 men convicted annually of
offences including harassment coercive
control and stalking against women
um and this has to be a good thing
surely um at the moment
we need to move on from this this
appalling murder
of sarah everard and if we can do
anything positive to encourage women to
come forward to report
crimes assault sexual assault even
domestic violence against men
um it has because women so at the moment
are so
wary of coming for because they feel
they're not being listened to by the
authorities
and if there is a database surely any
woman is going to think right okay
well i can get this person registered so
it might protect other women from being
attacked in the sort of van
it's actually modeled on the sex
offenders register which is established
in 1997
and that holds information about those
cautioned convicted and released from
prison
for sexual offences against children and
it's under a full disclosure scheme
uh sarah's law remember our um sarah
payne the eight-year-old murder victim
you can go there and you can find out if
somebody has been convicted
of these crimes and i think what is why
shouldn't we
have the database of of men who have
assaulted and attacked women it surely
makes sense it does sound like common
sense uh very quickly marianne tell us
about
uh green chocolate eggs in time
for easter they sound yummy
yeah so basically um a lot of brands
have responded to
increased consumer demand around
basically using less single-use plastic
so you know you used to get easter eggs
in massive boxes with all sorts of
crappy plastic toys and plastic
packaging and casing and stuff
they're basically in that not actually
the color green but they're
environmentally friendly
thank you both for taking us through the
papers dawn and mary ann good to see
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you